これは、youtubeの近い未来の話である
強力な人気を手に入れたyoutuberは
国家権力並みの力を持ち、勢力を拡大し、
まるでひとつの国のように動き始め
youtuberたちは、お互いを潰し始めた
6万円もするから多分ね、最高レベルのエアガンなんです
この銃は、なかなかすげえ腕のようで
1発打つだけで、3発分弾が出るみたいな
最強のエアガンらしいです
1回実際に撃ってみましょう
(泣)
うおっ、わ、わ
入りました
撃ってみます
弾切れか？もう弾なくなっちゃった
ご覧の通り、1箇所に3発ずつくらい弾が飛んでっているのがわかると思います
ガチでガチもんだこれ多分
これ絶対こうなるの？
そもそもなぜ私がこんなものを買ったかの理由の説明をしよう
まあ今、現在youtuberに求められるってものは様々なんですよ
編集力、撮影技術、いろんなものがyoutuberには求められるんですけども
今のyoutubeの世界で求められるものは、そんなもんじゃない
今のyoutuberに求められる唯一の力はそう!
編集技術とか撮影能力っていうのはねもうね
遅いっす
これからのyoutubeの時代に必要なのは戦闘能力です
物理的な攻撃が増えてくる
やっぱりyoutuberもね、登録者が多くなるとね、実力行使に出て
直接やり合うことが多くなってきたんで
まあ、みんなyoutuberは口に出さないんですけど
実際かなり武力的な争いが起きています
今の日本のyoutuber
非常に危ない
僕もこのままだと、他のyoutuberに襲われて、やられてしまうかもしれない
物理的にね
非常に危険な世界までもうyoutubeは進んでるんで
僕は今回その戦いに勝つためにこういう道具を買ったんですけども
今からyoutube始めようと思っているそこの君
必要とされるものは編集技術でもない、撮影能力でもない
戦闘能力だ
今のyoutuberは戦闘能力こそが全てのものをいう
いつ襲われてもいいように日々の特訓を欠かさず行うことが今後のyoutubeに必要になってくる
はっ!　もうyoutuberが来ている
では早速、戦闘準備に入る
よし、では行こう！
(youtuberは住所を特定されやすいので、直接家を襲撃されることが多い）
くそぅ...
youtuberめ...
♪　ビートボックス
なんだこのビートボックスは...
っは...
♪　ビートボックス
まさか...
やはり親分でしたか...
♪　ビートボックス
今日は容赦しませんよ...
いくぜ！！！！！！
♪　ビートボックス
スリー　トゥー　ワン！
FIRE!!!!!!!!
♪　ビートボックス
ダダダダダダダダダダダダダ…(銃撃音)
戦闘力では俺のほうが上だったようですね
親分...
♪　気持ち悪い食べる音
なんだこの食べ物を食べる大きな音は…
上か！
木下ゆうか：ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊｰ ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊｰ
木下さんまで戦闘民族に....
っく...それでも俺は...!
やるしかねえんだああ！
木：ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊｰ
スリートゥ
ーワン…
木：ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊｰ
FIRE!
ドン！(銃撃音)
木：ｺﾝn...
木：ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊｰ
俺は女を傷つけない主義でね...、気を付けな...
トミック：俺はね、キング・オブ・キッチンとs…
ダダダダダダダダダダダダダ…(銃撃音)
そらちぃ：はいどうもアバンティーズのそらｔ…
そ：今回の企画はこちらです！
出直してきな...
♪　ビートボックス
なんだこのビートボックスは
まさか...
♪　ビートボックス
このビートボックスは...
Daichi：Hello!　Hajime!
♪　ビートボックス
だ、Daichiさん...
D：ｺﾝﾆﾁﾊ ｺﾝﾊﾞﾝﾊ ｵﾊﾖｳ
Daichiさん...
俺にあなたは撃てない...!
D：ﾒﾉﾏｴﾆﾊﾌﾞﾗｼ ﾒﾉﾏｴﾆﾊ
完全にイカレち
ﾌﾞﾗｼ
まってる…(泣)
♪　ビートボックス
それでも俺は...
あなたを撃つ!!
うおおおおおおお
おおおおおおおお(銃撃音)
♪　ビートボックス